Google cloud is one of the largest
Platforms in the world and today as we
all know especially after covid the
world is moving online in today's
environment the complexity there is no
one cloud provider and in that
environment we think that the Google
platform the gcp cloud environment is
one of the safest and securest platforms
out there Sedaris is the world's largest
independent co-managed and managed
services company we tend to deal with
very large Enterprise customers and what
we hear is we hear a cry for help
help me with more security help me with
more data help me with more compliance
for us to provide value to our customers
we need a platform that provides value
to us and our customers we've been a
Chronicle partner for many years and we
went to Google because we needed a
robust platform that would allow us to
adjust any kind of data at volume and
that's really one of the advantages of
Chronicle and Google at the same time
ingesting data is one thing but making
sense of it on the back end is another
we're big fans of Chronicles soar and
more importantly the workbooks and the
playbooks we can create at tremendous
value in automation for our customers we
think Google made a strategic decision
in the way that they built the platform
many years ago not only is it highly
robust and has millisecond search
capability across vast amount of data
but it gives you an unlimited amount of
storage compared to the other platforms
I'm super excited about security AI
workbench if you think of AI at its most
simplest core it's really deep data and
it's really Surge and then taking those
things combining it into something that
provides intelligence especially in
security with threads and data who's one
of the largest data companies in the
world Google
super excited about the capability there
I've been doing cyber security longer
than time exists and if we know one
thing we know that the world is becoming
more complicated and the threats are
greater than ever at the same time
against that backdrop we have tremendous
pressure on Enterprises today from a
compliance and privacy perspective
greater threats more compliance
you need a managed service partner to
help you provide that but we also need a
strong partner to help us do a great job
for our customers we partner with Google
in order to have that platform to give
our customers that level of visibility
and security because at the end of the
day
isn't it really just about reducing risk
good